hello and welcome to say your plane Alex
lucky Alex lucky but Alex unluckiest
always got my almost my rating alright
okay this is that seen so often nowadays
the 93 variation before is a strange
move it's normally not played here at
all
the insertion of those two moves is very
favorable for black due to this idea and
now White has to yea struggle a little
bit to get the pawn back it takes a bit
of time
and now black has no problems here at
all okay now it's interesting yeah I
think we should take
how do we how do we play this Thank You
P position Edison
a little bit there's some unusual points
about it the Queen on e5 and also the
traded the traded minor pieces are
interesting
the night's yeah I'm wondering if I can
play with a quicker route da this is my
idea here it should be too
should be too
should be to look the age nine
five
there came 58 if he goes specialty to
Luke da to Bishop Knight b5 I can go
Bishop before actually this is
interesting
fine yeah I think I'm okay here right
should be quite fine with roopd aid he
has some No
obvious
possibility in this position interesting
doesn't look very scary but
you
young that is definitely not very scary
okay taking 195 is also
you
like so much to take the same
develop his queen but on the other hand
I'm letting him take one c6 doesn't seem
right either
you
okay
I was actually thinking that yeah okay
it's not so great we should be seven
cakes King takes was my original
intention but that it's not so great
I don't really have a good
of fleeing this
surprising yeah
f6 is not a move you would like to play
ah
mmm it's odd remember my blockade that
squares so fairly okay so I don't think
my position were
oops that quickly but
I think at the very beginning my
position was was completely fine and
this position here is not fine
mean find in the sense of that I thought
I would rather be better than anything
else and that is definitely not the case
now
don't
what is he doing here I don't quite
see the point
they push th pawn knots for an attack
but if I wanted to get to look into the
game that's my problem that's my issue
with the King on evade you can play some
four moves King g7 or try to do that or
you can go with this approach to give
the rook some ideas and now look h6s
just around the corner
which is still a bit strange but
it is doing something
mmm night Survival I'm not not certain
boys
I did not mind dad
all of a sudden gets an open file
certainly
something
that annoys me all that much
came
discovering age five
maybe I should have just take
the bloody pawn
could have just taken the pawn
you
you
I cannot even play King g7 oh my god
what a silly game to lose I'm such a
[ __ ] iam and there's a frustrating game
because he just played well very badly
wishes everything else is too nice who's
just getting totally outplayed I am such
a [ __ ]
yeah that was silly it was efficacy
which is basically over here mean I'm
just a pawn up and window this is
weekend
he's got no plane ready a very silly to
okay five
yeah even so Quimby ain't but I didn't
know I was just having a blackout yeah
it's a bit a bit of a shame because like
okay well info was just just a mistake
in the opening where white is fighting
for equality and yeah it's a bit it's a
shame
okay Bishop me six might be even better
but this is just this is very fine White
has a fairly prospectus position against
the iqp
and yeah you can argue if I can I can
probably improve this somehow this is
already quite comfortable yeah the
engine wants to play Bishop d6 which is
interesting so that after here this rook
c8 is possible
got d5 nicely covered it's just not a
good a QP all right so yeah this was a
bit odd yeah and probably good for Wyatt
you know up t7s this is a move that is
tough to make always think that some
Luke c1 could be could be an issue but
engine
[Music]
engine doesn't see oh yeah okay of
course like here this this is not a
problem I can do this
No okay so we had this
and then with h4 I was getting the rook
into the game
yeah they just gave me a pawn for
nothing and now I just have to convert
it g3 is well ultimately had won the
game for him because he opened the H
file but it is just okay just just not a
good idea then now just something normal
what what what what what's the best like
this I mean here I just have Queen f6
and White has no no play at all yeah
Cecilia and these are the games that
that make me not get over 2500 you
playing and somebody with equal rating
who is just ya know that I should score
heavily against and then something like
this costs lots of points okay guys
thanks for watching